[Musique]
on me dit qu'il n'ya que vous pour ce
travail et je vous demande l'impossible
[Musique]
je cherche quoi exactement la somme de
tous mes péchés
pas mal
[Musique]
lisbeth et mon pied j'ai pu décoller non
mais ça va pas tarder
tu es bien les spet salander la justice
hier la physio cette fois je te raconte
fille qui agressent les hommes qui
agressent les g prenez votre enfant et
partez ne vous rappelez de mal pourquoi
tu as une idée tout le monde sauf moi
un monsieur
c'est à l'est c'est elle qu'il est
derrière tout ça
elles sont france doit toujours peser
sur quelqu'un maintenant c'est ton tour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez cru qu'elle n'avait pas de
temps
le menton va s'embraser
et on saura que c'est toi
qui a déclenché leur temps
vous
[Applaudissements]